what's that believe nation I started to
mentor me series to try to learn from
people who've done a lot more than us
and by hanging around them a little bit
longer hopefully some of their
viewpoints their mindset their way of
thinking seeps into our brains to help
us become the best version of ourselves
so today we're going to learn from
Michelle Obama from some of her most
inspiring moments mentor me Michelle
rule number two is my personal favorite
and I'm curious to figure out which one
you guys like that and as always guys as
you're watching the videos if you see
something that really resonates with you
please leave it in the comments below
and put quotes around it so other people
can be inspired and if you write it down
it's much more likely to stick with
yourself as well
[Music]
when you are struggling and you start
thinking about giving up I want you to
remember something that my husband and I
have talked about since we first started
this journey nearly a decade ago
something that has carried us through
every moment in this White House in
every moment of our lives and that is
the power of hope the belief that
something better is always possible if
you're willing to work for it and fight
for it
it is our fundamental belief in the
power of hope that has allowed us to
rise above the voices of doubt and
division of anger and fear that we have
faced in our own lives and in the life
of this country our hope that if we work
hard enough and believe in ourselves
then we can be whatever we dream
regardless of the limitations that
others may place on us the hope that
when people see us for who we truly are
maybe just maybe they too will be
inspired to rise to their best possible
selves shoot is the hope of my folks
like my dad got up every day do his job
at the city water plant the hope that
one may his kids would go to college and
have opportunities he never dreamed of
that's the kind of hope that every
single one of us politicians parents
preachers all of us need to be providing
for our young people because that is
what moves this country forward every
single day I hope for the future and the
hard work that hope inspires one our
young people to know that they matter
that they belong so don't be afraid you
hear me young people don't be afraid be
focused
be determined be hopeful be empowered
empower yourselves with a good education
then get out there and use that
education to build a country worthy of
your boundless promise lead by example
with hope
never fear and know that I will be with
you rooting for you and working to
support you for the rest of my life and
that is true I know for every person who
were here today and for educators and
advocates all across this nation who get
up every day and work their hearts out
to lift up our young people and I am so
grateful to all of you for your passion
and your dedication and all the hard
work on behalf of our next generation
and I can think of no better way to end
my time as first ladies and celebrating
with all of you so I want to close the
day by simply saying thank you thank you
for everything you do for our kids and
for our country being your first lady
has been the greatest honor of my life
and I hope I've made you proud
you should never view your challenges as
a disadvantage instead it's important
for you to understand that your
experience facing and overcoming
adversity is actually one of your
biggest advantages and I know that
because I've seen it myself not just as
a student working my way through school
but years later when I be after I came
before I came to the White House and I
worked as the Dean at a college in that
role I encountered students who had
every advantage their parents paid their
full tuition they lived in beautiful
campus dorms they had every material
possession a college kid could want cars
computers spending money but when some
of them got their first bet great they
just fell apart they lost it because
they were ill-equipped to handle their
first encounter with disappointment or
falling short
life will put many obstacles in your
path that are far worse than a bad grade
you'll you'll have unreasonable bosses
and difficult clients and patients
you'll experience illnesses and losses
crises and setbacks that will come out
of nowhere and knock you off your feet
but unlike so many other young people
you have already developed the
resilience and the maturity that you
need to pick yourself up and dust
yourself up and keep moving through the
pain keep moving forward are you going
to throw up your hands and say that
progress will never come are you going
to get angry and lash out are you going
to turn inward and just give in to
despair and frustration or are you going
to take a deep breath straighten your
shoulders lift up your head and do what
Barack Obama has always done it he says
when they go long I go high
that's the choice Barack and I have made
that's what has kept us sane over the
years we simply do not allow space in
our hearts minds or souls for darkness
instead we choose faith faith in
ourselves in the power of hard work
faith in our God whose overwhelming love
sustains us every single day that's what
we choose we choose love our love for
our children our commitment to leaving
them a better world our love for our
country which has given us so many
blessings and advantages our love for
our fellow citizens parents working hard
to support their kids men and women in
uniform who risk everything to keep us
safe young people from the toughest
backgrounds who never stopped believing
in their dreams young people like so
many of you that's what we choose
and we choose excellence we choose the
two not all the noise and strive for
excellence in everything we do no
cutting corners no taking shortcuts no
whining
we give 120 percent every single time
because excellence excellence is the
most powerful answers you can give to
the doubters and the haters it's also
the most powerful thing you can do for
yourself because the process of striving
and struggling and pushing yourself to
new heights see that's how you develop
your god-given talents that's how you
make yourself stronger and smarter and
more able to make a difference for
others connect I've always felt a deep
sense of obligation to make the biggest
impact possible with this incredible
platform so I took on issues that were
personal to me issues like helping
families raise healthier kids honoring
the incredible military families that
I've met out on the campaign trail
inspiring our young people to value
their education and finish college now
some folks criticize my choices for not
being bold enough but these were my
choices my issues and I decided to
tackle them in a way that felt most
authentic to me in a way that was both
substantive and strategic but also fun
and hopefully inspiring so I immersed
myself in the policy details I worked
with Congress on legislation gave
speeches to CEOs military generals
Hollywood executives but I also work to
ensure that my efforts would resonate
with kids and families and that meant
doing things in a creative and
unconventional way so yeah I planted a
garden and hula-hooped on the White
House lawn with kids I did some mom
dancing on TV
celebrated military kids would Kermit
the Frog
I asked folks across the country to wear
their alma mater t-shirts for college
signing day and at the end of the day by
staying true to the me I've always known
I found that this journey has been
incredibly freeing because no matter
what happened I had the peace of mind of
knowing that all of the chatter the
name-calling the doubting all of it was
just noise it did not define me it
didn't change who I was and most
importantly it couldn't hold me back I
have learned that as long as I hold fast
to my beliefs and values and follow my
own moral compass then the only
expectations I need to leave live up to
are my own we want our children and all
children in this nation to know that the
only limits are the height of your
achievements is the reach of your dreams
and your willingness to work hard for
them and as our friendship grew and I
learned more about Barack's he
introduced me to work the work that he
done when he first moved to Chicago
after college you see instead of going
to Wall Street Barack went to work in
neighborhoods that had been devastated
by the closing of steel planes jobs
dried up and Barack was invited back to
speak to people from those neighborhoods
about how to rebuild their community and
the people gathered there together that
day were ordinary folks doing the best
they could to build a good life see they
were parents trying to get by from
paycheck to paycheck
grandparents trying to get it together
on a fixed income men frustrated that
they couldn't support their families as
their job had disappeared
you see those folks weren't asking for a
handout or a shortcut see they were
ready to work they wanted to contribute
they
leave like you and I believe that
America should be a place where you can
make it if you try and Barack stood up
that day and he spoke words that have
stayed with me ever since he talked
about the world as it is and the world
as it should be
and he said that all too often we accept
the distance between the two and we
settled for the world as it is even when
it doesn't reflect our values and
aspirations but he reminded us that we
also know what the world should life
look like he said we know what fairness
and justice and opportunity look like
and he urged us to believe in ourself to
find the strength within ourselves to
strive for the world as it should be
and isn't that the great American story
[Applause]
Sasori of men and women gathered in
churches and union halls in high school
gyms and people who stood up and marched
and risked everything they had refusing
to settle determined to mold our future
into the shape of our ideal thank you
guys so much for watching I'd love to
know what did you think of this video
what did you learn from Michelle that
you're going to immediately apply to
your life your business somehow please
leave it down in the comments below and
I'm going to join in the discussion I
also want to give a quick shout out to
Christy blad Christy thank you so much
for picking up a copy of my book your
one word and posting that YouTube video
review on your channel I really really
really appreciate the support I'm going
to tell you about a few insights that I
got from Evan Carmichael's this book
you're one word so thank you guys again
for watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one where it is much love
I'll see you soon